[Música]
gracias por seguir con nosotros y
bienvenidos a cinco minutos con carlos
eduardo pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia nos
acompaña doctor buen día para ustedes y
comienzo preguntándole estamos viendo
como europa está lidiando con nuevos
rebrotes del nuevo coronavirus la
población se enfrenta a posibles
restricciones cuál es la situación
la situación es que como había pasado en
la pandemia de 1918 después de unos
meses de una aparente calma aparecen
nuevos casos eso se explica porque hay
personas susceptibles porque se pierden
las medidas de distanciamiento físico
que han obligado la cuarentena previa y
al aumentar la interacción humana
aparecen casos generalmente son casos
más jóvenes en un mayor número con menor
número de muertos y es lo que estamos
viendo en españa en francia en el reino
unido- y el menor importancia en otros
países de europa como italia doctor
en esta segunda ola en europa podríamos
decir que es una señal de advertencia
para américa latina cómo está el
continente
definitivamente tenemos que aprender
esto no depende del comportamiento y
gael sino del comportamiento humano es
decir que no es que el virus
cíclicamente produzca a estas nuevas
infecciones sino es nuestro
comportamiento sin avisamos nuestro
comportamiento si permitimos el
acercamiento si no usemos el cubrebocas
es decir si nos relajamos en nuestras
medidas se aumenta la interacción y
solamente la posibilidad de nuevos casos
hay ejemplos como en italia que ha
producido menor incidencia de esta
segunda ola y de ahí debemos aprender
que nuestro comportamiento es lo que va
a definir si presentamos un rebrote y si
se presenta de qué magnitud
va a ser bueno doctor es conocido que
los países latinoamericanos están
lamentablemente en el top 10 de los
países más afectados por el nuevo
coronavirus de hecho colombia después de
brasil es el país con más contagios
confirmados en américa latina está este
país preparado hospitalariamente para
nuevos rebrotes
y lo que ha desnudado de esta pandemia
es la debilidad de los sistemas de salud
de muchos países no es bueno comparar
entre países el número de casos número
de fallecidos porque hay una
discrepancia la medición de algunos
países bien de una forma otros de otra
forma esto no se trata de esta
comparación lo que es cierto es que
nuestros sistemas son débiles en
prevención en educación y la capacidad
hospitalaria en este par de meses en
esos 34 meses se ha incrementado
razonablemente en 50 a 60 por ciento más
de cuidado intensivo de lo que teníamos
antes pero aquí el fracaso no es tener
unidad de juego el éxito no es tener
unidad de contenido sino que los
presentes no lleguen la unidad de
contención aquí no es tener más camas
hospitalarias sino más personal de salud
entrenado y el éxito es que la gente no
se hospitalice por eso nuestra
estrategia de enfocarse en la prevención
en la educación fortalecer los sistemas
hospitalarios y brindar estabilidad a el
personal de salud que tiene
y la siguiente pregunta es que estamos
viendo como esta segunda ronda de
restricciones está afectando muchísimo y
levantando malestar en la población en
general aquí sería un consejo para
nuestros televidentes de cómo prepararse
mentalmente para esto que sigue
pero nosotros tenemos que entender que
esta situación no va a pasar en un mes o
en dos meses la situación a una solución
definitiva debe ser hasta el segundo
semestre el 2021
teniendo las expectativas que de la
vacuna que está próxima próxima de cerca
de un año nosotros tenemos que
adaptarnos a que la realidad es nuestro
comportamiento sin duda las
restricciones nos obligan y nos hacen
sentir ansiosos pero si no las adoptamos
nos vamos a enfermar está en nosotros
crear esas estrategias con nuestros
hijos y nuestras familias para
adaptarnos a esta realidad para aceptar
estamos en una pandemia pero que debemos
salir a reactivar nuestra vida con
alegría con distanciamiento pero también
con optimismo y empezar a quitar esa
nube de pesimismo que nos agobia para
hacerla con optimismo hay personas que
lo han hecho bien y tenemos que seguir
esos ejemplos pero el llamado es a la
comunicación la pedagogía de la
tranquilidad y que el aislamiento
simplemente es tomar distancia para que
después nos unamos con mayor fuerza
doctor como siempre gracias a usted por
sus recomendaciones y a nuestros
televidentes recordar es siempre el uso
de tapabocas lavarse las manos y
mantener la distancia social que tengan
un buen día y sigan en france 24
[Música]